the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about how
Stark's fate about fate of Arya
sand-sized bran stark supported by a few
leaked photos leaked plot and of course
with few tears of mine if you're
wondering why I'm not including John in
this video or if you're thinking it's
because of the fact that John is on the
stark the answer is no you're not even
close John no matter of his actual
father will always be a stark for me and
yeah
the one and the only reason for not
including John in this video is because
I've already made a video recently
focused on only John's fate if you want
feel free to check it out let's start
with bran Starks fate in the upcoming
season
first of all let's highlight the fact
that from all of League photos they were
only taking a few photos of bran and
those photos weren't even from the
shooting set all the brand's leaked
photos if we can even call it leaked
we're taking while Isaac was preparing
for the shooting
Isaac Hampstead write to us known as a
brand was filming different scenes
recently some report says that the scene
in which bran was also included the Lord
said along with few members of the
Nights Watch last seen that involve bran
in previous season is the scene in which
benjin scored bran and Mira read near
the Castle black
so the Lakeridge says that Brown was
filming simi the Lord ad is not
surprising at all this means that bran
will pass beneath the wall which
confirms the bran is on his way to win
or fail just like League plot says don't
be too happy about it
be conscious the brown is mourned by
tonight King which will bring the real
trial to the Seven Kingdoms if he really
decides to pass the ball in the upcoming
season as we've already seen in season
six dr. Brown was marked by night King
the leader of the undead army now knows
where bran is and will come after him
furthermore the mark runs had likewise
can neutralize the magic that is screwed
into the wall as a protection from the
White Walkers and their whites how can I
tell for sure well the magic words
around the cave in which three-eyed
raven along with children of the forest
and brandenburg was neutralized by bran
smart from the night king which means
that anywhere bran goes the night king
will be able to go after
him no matter if some places contain
magic as a protection the night king
will pass with the help of his mark on
bronze hand while we are looking forward
to see full stark reunion at Winterfell
which were most likely going to see
brands presents also means great threat
for everyone else however I believe in
leaked plot which also said that bran
will pass the wall and drive to
Winterfell
most likely in the middle of season 7 if
you're wondering little Brown admit to
Jon Snow who his true parents really are
the answer is simply no he won't have an
opportunity at least not to the upcoming
season generally Winterfell and we'll go
to dragonstone before bran survival as
leaked photo confirmed bran will without
a doubt play major role in both season 7
and season 8 I'm sure that the upcoming
season will bring to us a lot of brands
flashbacks from which we are going to
find out a lot until now unexplored and
unexplained things like for an example
in my opinion it would be really helpful
if one of brands flashbacks would
include the tourney at Harrenhal
which would explain many things along
with the most important one did Rhaegar
Targaryen really kidnap Liana and if not
who has spread the lies this flashback
will give us the answers on so many
questions for me personally to finally
figured out why we drag or no as to one
of the most honorable and in many eyes
the kindest person in the Seven Kingdoms
kidnap Liana and possibly raped her
which I don't believe he did however
bronze flashback well in my opinion play
the important role in the upcoming
seasons now let's move on Arya there are
only a few photos so Maisie
which were taken while she was preparing
for a shooting while there are not
leaked photos of Arya there's one short
scene from HBO's official teaser of a
new season which actually gave us a lot
there is the only one quick scene of re
on horseback varying north clothes in my
opinion it's scene of arias trial at
Winterfell after all these years of
suffering she finally came back home and
that's her face expression with all
emotions in it
let's see Nefarian season 6 is so
satisfying scene in which Arya managed
her mother and her brother Rob by
killing Walder Frey with smile on her
face after she already butchered lower
roller sons and served their corpses to
Alder inside a pie after Aria told to
jacking Hegar who she really is and
where she is going a girl is our stark
Winterfell and I'm going home
it was easy to assume even before
official teaser was published the Tori
will reunite with bran and Sandra
Norville and that we are going to have a
full stark reunion before that reunion
happens or I will have an interesting
trip to Reno file full of the encounters
my first prediction is that on our way
home Oliver finally meet our dire wolf
Nymeria second most likely areas
encounter could be with Melisandre now
that Melisandre is heading south and
arias heading north and after Melisandre
is prophecy that she told to Arya I see
a darkness in you and in the darkness
eyes staring back at me brown eyes blue
eyes green eyes eyes that you'll shut
forever we will meet again surely
they'll meet again
Arya did shut all of these sighs the
only remaining thing of that prophecy to
happen is Melisandre meeting Aria again
our opinion is that Melisandre is
prophecy will come true in the first
episodes of the upcoming season the
question is how the meeting is going to
end well we know Arya and we know that
she is dedicated to decreasing the names
on her kill list and we also know that
Melisandre is on that list the possible
outcome could be are you killing
Melisandre after which lord of the light
would bring her back to life since she
has many things yet to do this is only a
possibility
while the sure thing is our s arrival in
Winterfell most likely in the middle of
season seven our will surely play a big
role in the upcoming season but me
personally will like more than anything
else to see unification between RA and
Jon well I'm sure won't happen until the
last season I'm going to talk about a
little more about Arya in few moments
let's now move on Sansa Starks fate in
season 7 there are only a few photos of
sophie Turner aka Sansa Stark and all of
those photos were taken while she was
either arriving or leaving the shooting
set which didn't give us a lot actually
it gave us absolutely nothing
while League photo gave us absolutely
nothing HBO's d0p new season gave us a
little bit more HBO's teaser of the
upcoming season is a short video with
four short scenes of which two scenes
include Sansa in the first part video
it's Sansa a lot of fans are saying that
she looks kind of weird which is because
of his turn decision to use a wig mostly
because her hair suffered a lot from
dying after all of these years
as we can see senses that gods would o
be no foul which is not any kind of
spoiler however she seems a little
surprised which leads me to assume that
this sync represent the first meeting
between brain and Sansa creepers and
senses first look at Bronn after all of
these years also there's one more scene
from the teaser which includes Sansa in
that scene john is talking to her in my
opinion this scene takes place while
John is telling the censor that he
received the invitation from Daenerys
and that he's going south while she is
now in charge of Winterfell the last
scene of sense in season 6 envisioned
Littlefinger having suspicious eye
contact many fans considered as senses
disappointment on John becoming the king
in the north and the rule of Winterfell
along with possible senses betrayal on
John Andrew Littlefinger while my
thoughts are that sense of what made me
do that if it all play a few years ago
but now I don't think so since it's the
word that Littlefinger is playing games
and is more than aware of that because
of him she got rate which helped Sansa
to figure out that Petyr Baelish would
let her suffer or even being killed if
that would bring him an Iron Throne all
of this in my opinion means that Sansa
might cooperate with Littlefinger in the
upcoming season
but now sense is the one that is going
to play games this is the one that is
going to manipulate Petyr Baelish it's
definitely going to be interesting to
see sense that's other side darker side
and also to see Littlefinger final being
played and manipulated with emotional
scenes between Arya bran and Sansa who
are finally going to reunite in the
upcoming season
they're also come to the fore the
prominent difference between two sisters
between Arya and Sansa Arya have always
had more rigid moral code while Sansa
has learned to be more
patek are a skill killer and wants
vengeance immediately with our skills
while Sansa has more sub though
manipulative way of doing things which
she has learned from Littlefinger having
developed two very different
perspectives Arya and Sansa will clash
or the matter of ruling for sense and
Arya would be very helpful to try to
understand each other and to team up
which they might do in future however
upon noticing the difference between two
sisters Petyr Baelish should probably
take a chance to take the advantage with
increasing conflict between Arya and
Sansa how will it end for Littlefinger
for that answer we have to wait for
season seven it's my tenth Victoria
pulling finger hero kill list so we
don't have to explain you what would
happen to Littlefinger after that
another possible outcome could be as
I've already said sense the manipulating
Petyr Baelish during bigger amount of
the upcoming season and she get all she
wants then she would kill him as a
revenge for Littlefinger for putting her
in hands of Ramsay and also for
betraying her father Ned Littlefinger
played the main role and is guilty for
Sansa being raped so it will represent
sense of strength once again just like
when she killed Ramsay in my opinion
Starks are definitely going to find out
about Littlefinger's betrayal Ned but
the main question is how there are a lot
of possibilities such as Jon finding out
from various well is the Dragonstone but
my favorite will be brand finding out in
one of his flashbacks in my opinion that
would be the best way don't you think
this is in my opinion bait of the two
remaining Starks in the upcoming season
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and uh yeah
see you next one peace
[Music]